well hello there you're watching the
press preview a
first look then at what is on the front
pages in the next half hour then we will
see what's making the headlines with the
political editor of the daily mirror
pippa crea
and the political editor of the sun
harry cole
and after 11 they will stay with me to
give their take on the stories of the
night
very grateful thank you front pages then
let's take a look shall we the financial
times leads with the uk
the eu and the us all considering
sanctions
against the government of belarus after
it had a flight diverted
to minsk so a prominent opposition
journalist could be arrested
the metro describes the belarusian
regime as pirates of europe's skies
marcus rashford's plea to the government
to help hungry children is on the front
page
of the mirror as mps debate the england
footballer's petition
calling for extra assistance for
struggling families
the daily mail leads with its splash on
the number of british firms that have
been sold off to private equity
since the start of the coronavirus
outbreak
the delhi telegraph understands that a
new raft of
coveted rules will stipulate that even
people
who are fully vaccinated will still have
to self-isolate
for 10 days if they come into contact
with someone with
covid and a guardian investigation has
found that 8
700 people died of the virus having
caught it in hospitals
where they were being treated for other
conditions
more babies still to come in we will
take a look at those when we get them
we'll join them for the next 90 minutes
by pippa creer and harry cole
welcome thank you very much indeed for
uh bravely kicking us off with this one
but let's get to the main story for us
and the main story for many of the
newspapers then
uh which is the metro the pirates of
europe skies
and what we do about belarus harry what
do you reckon
yeah it's just an astonishing story
we've had a spate of these in in recent
weeks of stories that
i've been sitting there at my desk
writing and they could be from
a different time a time gone by we had
the jersey blockade which
read something out sounds like something
out of the napoleonic wars
and then this which it could have been
straight out of a uh
a cold war thriller um just an
astonishing
breach of all uh international rules and
and norms and uh and any
modern precedent for for this really um
and
one that's slightly left i think uh the
eu the uk and the us slightly sort of
just
you know always with their jaws on the
floor uh and
what can they actually do um you know
there's obviously questions around
the kremlin's involvement with belarus
given that the proximity
location and the history of the
relationship between those two countries
but beyond actually um beyond actually
you know
shutting our airspace and and and
sending off
increasingly angry statements um this is
a bit of a pickle
um because actually what what what can
uh what can any other country do that's
a suitable response to this clear
fragrant breach of
of the law but isn't going to kick off
from world war three
well you know that that's that's that's
a step that took me by surprise to be
to be fair calling it that and one hopes
pippa
that the international community had
already taken action over what they
described as a stolen election
by alexander lukashenko protesters
thrown in jail after weeks and weeks of
of protests across many cities in
in belarus so so exactly that's the
point what more can they do when
hopefully they've
already done something yes and you do
wonder whether vladimir putin is sitting
there
watching it or rubbing his hands in glee
because of course any action
beyond sort of condemnation that
international leaders be it
the eu or the white house take against
belarus
if it ends up isolating belarus all it
ends up doing is pushing
them closer to uh to moscow and
sort of you know strengthening that
alliance um i mean i
you know harry and i both journalists
we're all journalists here and
i sort of sit and watch how uh
this uh this belarusian um
blogger uh he had he ran a telegram
channel and through it he obviously
he organized or helped organize some of
those protests against the election
results that you that you mentioned
there anna um
he has been singled out in quite an
extraordinary way i mean to divert a
whole civilian aircraft
to um away from his flight path
apparently on the personal origins of
lukashenko it's really quite something
and there was apparently bella russian
kgb
agents on the flight with him uh and
when also
they landed in minsk and he was he was
whisked away with his girlfriend to
prison and we've had this really
striking video tonight
of him uh doing an interview in which
he's claiming he's been well treated
well you know
what you don't see is what happens when
the camera goes off but as journalists
it is really striking that we
in comparison live in a completely
different world i mean we can
criticize our governments and that we
regularly do at the mirror
um you know to as much as we want and
we do not expect to end up thrown into
thrown into prison and to to have sort
of like an astonishing event
uh like this to take place yes i suppose
he was blamed wasn't he for
for many of those massive protests we we
saw because he ran this
popular messaging app that played a key
role in helping organize those protests
so as far as the
as the government and belarus were
concerned you know he was a big deal
but you've got the g7 coming up uh in a
couple of weeks two and a half weeks
harry
you've had all these misdemeanors around
the world in the last few years from
you know putin and and supposedly
state-sponsored novichok poisoning
jamal khashoggi you've got this um it
feels like certain nations are
emboldened
or no longer respect or fear the west
so what do these g7 leaders do about
this sort of the geopolitics i haven't
even mentioned
china and the weakers there it goes on
doesn't it
yeah well of course you know can't kick
out uh russia once again from uh from
that grouping
but again this goes back to my point i
was making earlier is when
when states are clearly willing to act
with such
uh you know with such willingness to
break all norms and rules
it does it does put leaders into a
seriously tricky situation
i think the good news is to some degree
we
will have a more conventional united
states um at the g7 in fact it's
actually happening
this time as opposed to the one uh
delayed last year by donald trump the
one before that i think
was the brilliant one where he refused
to sign the communique at the end
and ended up having a sort of row in
front of cameras with uh with angela
merkel and co
so i think we might get a slightly more
conventional joined up
west um at the g7 but let's go to that
point of of you know beyond sanctions
and
and targeting you know we've got some
new powers to target individuals and
uh who break the rules and you know
global sanctions regimes are
do have teeth but if people are willing
just to
to you know to not play by the rules of
the international order
it's very hard to come the conventional
response yes absolutely the ft then as
well belarus faces
the threat of western reprisals after
aviation piracy
already we know uh action has been taken
in the air the banning of
you know the belarusian carrier flight
paths and so on so action's already
being taken isn't it but we'll certainly
see how that
plays out but a great deal of angst and
anger about uh
about what happened in the skies
certainly um should we move on
uh pippa to the daily telegraph
this is the big question about once
you're vaccinated how are you allowed to
behave
and the delhi telegraph suggesting that
even
the vaccinated will still have to
self-isolate
yeah and this front page if you just
read the headline it's quite striking
isn't it you sort of think
well hang on a second if surely one of
the benefits of being vaccinated twice
means that i can resume
some sort of normal life particularly as
we're at this stage of the pandemic
we're sort of one step off
emerging from the road map entirely but
then if you read into it
it's clear that you know we all know
that while the vaccination
can prevent serious illness and
hospitalizations and the good news this
week looks like it
is that it will do the same with the
indian variant as it has done with
previous variants and will help protect
people
what it doesn't do is stop transmission
entirely
and actually there's still a quite high
chance of
um of transmitting coronavirus
regardless of whether you've had the
vaccination or not you might you won't
get symptoms yourself
but you could still pass it on to others
and because there are still so many
people that haven't had
both vaccinations i think about i think
we're on about um is it 30 million now
that have had one vaccination
and um and then of course there's many
many more younger people
and also people in uh older groups or
potentially vulnerable that haven't been
vaccinated
there are still plenty of people at risk
so
this decision this is behind this
decision that is apparently going to
um continue that um if you come into
contact with somebody with coverage you
you need to
to self-isolate and you know we just the
last couple of weeks started talking
about this return to abnormality and how
in only a few short weeks time we might
be able to
lift all social distancing rules so for
example you can go to the pub and
instead of ordering
at your table you can go and stand at
the bar and order a pint and
chat to the you know chat to somebody
behind the bar there and so
potentially also not having to wear face
masks anymore um and
yet here we are it feels like there's
actually going to still be this big
element
of um of like government control and and
sort of having to
to take care potentially for some time
to come
um so you know again i guess it's just
like another reminder that
even in the uk when we're doing so well
with vaccination role we're like
we're not there yet and i suppose
there's a safety first
argument to this which takes us to the
guardian harry
8700 people died after catching covid
in hospital this was a really big
concern for many people certainly
um up to 8700 according to official
nhs data obtained by the guardian and
the question is whether people would
still feel safer
wearing face masks and keeping their
distance certainly indoors do you think
we
our behavior will change as patrick
valence suggested a couple of weeks ago
absolutely if you look at the impact
that previous uh
pandemics had on on
asian countries where mask wearing is on
public transport if you've got a runny
nose is is considered the norm
um i think we've i think for a very long
time we will be
you know if you've come into someone
with coverage you will be forced into
isolation regardless of
of uh of whether you've had the vaccine
they talk about it in terms of
protecting the vaccine rollout
and it will be part of the sort of new
yeah a new normal things you know
people that haven't we've talked about
this before on this very program
people haven't quite woken up yet to the
fact that the new normal post-pandemic
world
is going to be different in some ways
and i think this is a
key example of that i think it will feel
very different in july if the prime
minister gets his wish
to be able to drop wearing masks in pubs
and shops in workplaces
by law but obviously people are going to
be encouraged to to wear them if they
want to
i think so the 1.5 meter social distance
thing
is really crucial to to get to to lift
in order to get
people back into the workplaces but i
won't be surprised if next christmas and
the years to come
people carry on wearing masks on on the
tube it's just uh it
almost seems you know like common sense
and an odd that we didn't before
yeah interesting we will see how people
react to that certainly
harry pippa plenty more in just a moment
including a controversial figure in
sport
and the press we will discuss the legacy
of max mosley
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now paper career
and harry cole welcome back to both of
you
um to the daily mirror then pippa why
didn't you uh kick us off on this is
marcus rashford still making his efforts
felt this is certainly amongst the
politicians then
yes so you will remember whale that
marcus rashford forced
two government u-turns on free school
meals
uh last year and tried to have been
campaigning on child poverty
for a long time i mean he's talked
obviously in the past of
he himself uh having forced himself to
sleep two or three times a week his
child
because he was hungry and this latest uh
this latest intervention by him is
basically designed to force the
government to adopt its own
national food strategy which it's drawn
up but hasn't yet implemented
and marcus rashford is understandably
very frustrated with
this when you consider that we live in a
country where there's no shortage of
food
just apparently a shortage of money to
pay for it and he would like the
government
to expand its provision of
its brand access to free school meals
provide more meals and activities during
the school holidays and also to expand
the healthy start scheme these are not
just his ideas or the opposition ideas
these are
in fact the government's own ideas and
it seems quite incredible really
particularly
during a pandemic where we've seen so
many people suffering
so many people out of work and
access to food banks rising demand fuse
banks rising
but the government hasn't moved quicker
on this i mean even if you strip out
sort of the humanity of it
on a political level you might expect
them to recognize
that letting kids go hungry is not a
good look for any political party and
they were damaged by it last year
and you think that they'd want to act
sooner rather than later